Is there anything you take to help the liver regardless of cause?
Well, you're helping support your clean out your liver, so yes, milk thistle, pun 1 or
pun 1 phase 2 product or phase 2.5 and phase 3 product, their main purpose to help clean
out the liver, doing castor oil packs over the liver, doing coffee enemas, you know, doing
more coffee enemas per day. And again, remember, the purpose of coffee enemas is not because
you're constipated, that's a side effect of helping with constipation, but it's to help
stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system to help stimulate the flushing of your liver.
And remember, you're look back at that detoxification, seven phases of detoxification, remember, you
all have access to all our courses. The seven phases of detoxification talk about, okay,
here's a common scenario. I can't detoxify, you know, why liver markers are high. You've got
to look downstream from that. Do you have a blocked gallbladder, especially as a female?
Very common. You have a sluggish blocked gallbladder. What's going to help with that? Well, castor
oil packs really good for that coffee enemas are really good for that. So, book downstream from
where there's issues.